I know that you have a teenage
stepdaughter I do and she's a huge
Taylor Swift and you are as well and you
actually kind of know Taylor Swift
you've met her and so you were able to
arrange an amazing backstage opportunity
with Taylor yeah we were shooting the
show in Montreal and Taylor was coming
to perform and so I had met her before
and had her her contact but I thought oh
gosh I mean how many emails does she get
a day probably was a per actual email it
was her actual email right you know that
later I emailed her and I said I know
this is really last minute but my
stepdaughters in town and she you know
if we could see the show and say hi that
would be amazing and didn't really
expect anything back and like within
five minutes like yes come you know come
and see the show and that is so cool
yeah you were able to well I think the
greatest thing about about her is that I
think she really wants to create great
memories for people you know I've
noticed that with the the audience but
they're just individual she takes her
fan connection really serious guys yeah
she wants to make it great which I think
this I think that's an amazing thing for
your stepdaughter to see you be able to
do how many kids say I would love to go
to a Taylor Swift concert and you're
able to say hold on
I'll talk to Taylor I didn't have back
then to be honest I feel hopeless up I
always say that I always say that to
many kids and then I pretend to be on
the phone and I'm like what's that
trapped in an elevator
okay this shows been canceled you know
that mother in the world I feel like I
got a lot of points for that though
where are your seats then we were
sitting at the sound board which is sort
of you like the sound board that was
pretty amazing and it's such a great
show if I wrote the sound board and this
is just me I would be manipulating I
would be manipulating levels I just
there's too many knobs and levers I'd be
doing it oh man she's and she walks down
that kind of you know runway and you're
just she's amazing yeah right
I've yeah I shot something with her once
I have not been to a Taylor Swift
concert you have not I have not
yeah I got to go sometime Mike
my daughter loves Taylor Swift and is
gone but she's gone like with friends
and I have not gone to atella yeah but
if I go by myself it looks weird you
know if I go I need to bring a lot of
kids with you yeah